how are you doing today
great how are you steve i'm doing
excellent all right
so i'm gonna start with uh i guess when
i was watching the movie i started
thinking to myself
um is this like were you when you made
this film i just butchered my beginning
i was trying to
uh when you made this film were you
thinking um
i really wanted to know what would
happen if
the child from space had not landed um
from and this would be like you know in
an alt universe this is what actually
this is another version of their lives
that's exactly what i wanted that was
exactly my motivation
what would have happened to the kent if
uh
uh no not really not really nobody
the thing about that film man of steel
is yeah they were great together
um yeah they had great chemistry and
obviously they're
it's their ketchup and mustard it's
ridiculous you look at them together and
it's obvious right and so i wanted to
know what i wanted to know is
how early on in this process were you
thinking about the two of them
um can you sort of share that sure
you know what the thing i'll share is
that i don't really think about actors
while i'm writing because
because you never win the lottery
like i actually did in this instance so
if i had allowed myself to dream it
would have been them but i
i didn't um you know i it it's
anyway they're i mean i just i got so
lucky i got so lucky
no completely their their chemistry
together in that and in this
is fantastic and i i i mean
i need them to make more movies together
right right
you know but but actually i'll go see
them right exactly but i am curious
though because
kevin costner is such a good actor diane
obviously as well
but costner is the type of uh actor that
people
will watch almost anything he does yeah
he's he's one of those kind of actors
so can you sort of share what it was
like meeting with him for the for the
first time
knowing my god i really want this person
to be in my movie
oh no and then i'm going to say add on
top of that the fact that i'm a huge fan
so you know you're going you it's sort
of like going and seeing mount rushmore
for the first time
it's it's a little awe striking um but
he was
incredibly kind and
i would also i really want to say sort
of through the entire process like he's
on top of being the spectacular actor
you cite him as he's
a brilliant filmmaker and he's like he's
a brilliant director but he is
also a consummate storyteller
and he would i mean i just i'm grateful
for his generosity
to me in sort of going through the whole
process
with me and you know i i between the two
of them
i mean their level of experience versus
mine
is anyway they were they were gentle
they were gentle to me uh one of the
things that i really liked about
uh costner's character is that
he really doesn't speak a lot and he
only speaks sort of when he has to
um can you sort of talk about how early
on
um and i'm sure that was in the book or
like can you talk about
how early on you realized he was gonna
have like minimal dialogue and
you know i knew right away it was sort
of in in the in larry watson's
spectacular novel um it was one of the
things that really drew me i
it was how even margaret doesn't talk
that much that they
are it was
the it was exciting to me the
opportunity
to paint a portrait of a marriage with
all sort of behavioral subtext they
don't talk a lot you know there's a
scene where they they have just dropped
their
grandson off at his new home and they go
home and
she's standing by a sink and you never
see her face and you know she's
falling apart and he doesn't know how to
reach out to her
and there's sort of no dialogue and
it was those were the scenes that were
the most fun to do and that they
in both kevin and diane knew the
opportunities
um because it's all about performance
it's as as a writer
as a as a director my favorite scenes
to direct are the ones where i've given
you no dialogue
i'm always curious to talk to directors
about the editing process
because it is the final rewrite um
what did you learn from early friends
and family screenings
that impacted the finished film um
it's interesting because this is the
third i worked with jeff jeff ford
who uh this is our third he's
my brother-in-arms this is our third
time together
um and he's done all the avengers movies
um
we what did we what did we learn early
um i think the
it wasn't i had it was designed this way
was there's when in the first five
minutes of the movie when they're
so i'm not giving anything away when
their son dies and kevin finds him
it cuts to black and then
you're in their bedroom and diane is
tying kevin's tie
and you think you're they're going to a
funeral and then you realize they're
going to this
wedding of their daughter-in-law and it
was designed to be confusing
that you would think it was a funeral
and then it's revealed
a second later that it's a wedding and
i it was so gratifying when we did a
test
audience and it was a thing
they weren't confused they were confused
it was a pleasurable confusion
that they people liked the misdirect and
it was it was designed that way so i
felt
vindicated uh you got uh g
kino to join you again yeah do the score
um at this as at this point where is it
uh like you just text him and be like
please come back let's work it together
again
yeah no it's it's um i mean it's sort of
the i'm
the you know the the brotherhood of the
traveling pants with um
with michael and with jeff ford my
editor where it's just
when are you gonna have a script let's
go let's go let's go let's do it i'm
there
um so i'm if you don't mind
if you don't mind me asking i believe
this is uh michael's first time doing a
score like this
it is yeah and so can you sort of talk
about obviously he's such a gifted
um composer but did you sense any sort
of
like different energy because this is a
completely different genre for him
sure it was one of the things that
michael and i it was we were
both excited about was how different it
was
for me um the genre
and then for him also he had not done a
western before
and you know there's a lot of uh there's
an old compose
stephen forrester um uh composer and
that you sort of hear
it it feels very michael does this great
when we did family stone together i
always said it was um
it's the presbyterian piano that he he
sort of does that
and this feel has that americana
you know it evokes that so masterfully
it the the trick was figuring out um
not to go too on the nose and have all
guitar
and then um so it's guitar and piano
but he's i just you couldn't ask to work
with anybody better
oh he's a genius um on that note i
already have to stop i'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie what happened to
our time
yeah i know it goes really really fast
um and definitely write something else
for diane
and kevin and yeah because they're
fantastic yeah yeah
thanks so much